546,000 views 443,000 views 6 years old
and four years old but what were the
results like from like creating videos
like that was like an Amazon link and
then like did good money come in from
doing those oh um so I kind of it's been
a while since I an since I sort of
analyzed those videos so I noticed that
this company had no videos on how to use
the machine so again I invested it it
was fairly expensive it was about
$650 to buy the machine I did an
unboxing video and then I did a very
comprehensive video on how to use it so
I think that video got over 300,000
views so I made some pretty decent um
affiliate money and I will say this the
sewing machine video in general anything
with sewing machines has a very high CPM
like we're talking over
$30 and an RPM of like $15 to $20 so
that's actually a very good type of
video and i' I'm sure you can probably
find examples in other niches like for
Tech or anything else there's going to
be certain types of videos that have a
much higher CPM than normal like my
normal CPM is probably like $151 to $15
that one is over 303 $35 so I made
several thousand dollars from that video
and then I had linked linked to Amazon
and in fact I'm doing this with this
machine currently I I definitely paid
for the machine with all of the ad
Revenue
and I probably
made I I tried to keep track it's kind
of hard with Amazon but I definitely
made thousands and thousands of dollars
from from affiliate Revenue the
obviously the Amazon program they've
kind
of they've definitely kind of uh reduced
their commission rate so at the time I
think you could make like 8 to 10% on a
machine also during covid sewing
machines were harder to get and the
price of that machine jumped up to
$11,000 so every time somebody bought
one I probably made $50 to $75 and a lot
of people bought from that link so I'll
say this too if you have a video that
does really well or a series of videos
keep making those types of videos strike
while the iron is hot I think one
mistake I made is that even though these
were doing Gang Busters I kept doing
other V Rando videos and I should have
just did I should have gone a lot harder
on making videos about the pe800 then
the p900 came out about a year or two
ago so I bought that one as well to try
to make videos on it and those did
pretty well but not as good as the pe800
and also the p900 was way more expensive
but then I also saw brother was making
this machine this is called the brother
sketch and this is a very it's a very
weird machine for the industry and it
was only 500 bucks I was like I think I
can make the ad Revenue back if I get
the machine and what I didn't real and
that this video did pretty well I think
it'll do better over time because this
is actually kind of a controversial
embroidery machine because brother has
made it so
that the it's controlled solely via an
app and people are very upset about it
and when they first released the machine
all of the features to all of the good
features that you would need to use it
were behind a pay wall that costs
$112.99 a month I don't know about you
but I'm kind of sick of everything
turning into a subscription so I did a
few videos explaining to people because
I felt like the company was kind of
trying to hide the fact that in order to
really use this you had to pay $13 a
month so I did a few videos and people
that they kind of gained traction just
because of like they were a little more
polarizing and people were very upset
about what brother was doing with the
pay wall and with the app stuff and
after I did the videos I got an email
from Brother which I ignored and then
they ended up changing the policy to put
the important features in the free
version so I was very happy to possibly
contribute to a positive thing a
positive change that this company did
because a lot of people didn't know that
about it it got it definitely paid for
itself just in the ad Revenue I can
continue to make more videos with the
machine so sometimes it's good to invest
in things that you know are going to be
sort of hot in your Niche that are
popular that are new and the CPM for
these videos are also over $30 but um
just a one example you know that you can
get something that's kind of new and
talked about and buy it I also bought
another piece of tech that was fairly
expensive for the channel that I'm going
to do videos on just because people want
to see real reviews and I think one
thing that people appreciate about my
channel is that these are not sponsored
videos I paid for it myself so I think
viewers feel like they can trust the
information more because I went out and
bought it with my own money and I don't
have to worry about the company kind of
interjecting with the content or trying
to tell me what to say or you know like
getting their bad list I don't really
care and I'm making enough I I feel like
at this level I think one positive thing
about having a sizable channel is that
you can then have the money to buy
things yourself and not again I I
understand as a small Creator it's hard
and you kind of do have to rely
sometimes on getting free products but I
am sort of glad to be in a position
where I have a little bit more leverage
with these companies and where I can
also afford to buy equipment myself to
review so I love that story and it uh is
cool to hear your results and this is
one of my favorite strategies you call
it RSP review specific products or TSS
teach specific skills related to
something that a community loves what
you've been doing with sewing machines I
did so deeply with cameras and tripods
and Tech and lighting but this is one of
the biggest aspects of video riket
Academy again not that it's the only
strategy or that it needs to apply all
the time to all of us but when you're
just starting out you're able to review
somebody else's product you don't have
to create your own you talk about
somebody else's thing you don't have to
worry about shipping or fulfillment or
customer service through the power of
affiliate marketing you shared so many
nuggets there this is just again such a
great way to start and a great way to
create passive income rank a video
connected to affiliate marketing so
that's being viewed like Jen talked
about ad Revenue can come in over the
years and even thousands of dollars in
affiliate income and those numbers can
go up and down and um different things
can shift but imagine having 10 videos
ranked bringing you passive income 30
videos ranked bringing you passive
income that was how I was originally
able to go full-time doing this with a
tech Channel um called think media was
talking about cameras talking about
lighting talking about software ranking
videos and then eventually replacing my
income so I could be My Own Boss and
start building up with think media is
day